yeah hey guys this is the other show I'm
Chris and this is and we're here to talk
about episode 9 which is his first album
it's the plain bottle episode we're here
with Drew and Helene and Molly Shannon
you know if this plane goes down the
headlines gonna read chase dreams ,
others died in plane crash we are common
others first of all yeah if we were on a
plane it would say Molly Shannon comma
Thursday the example that we had in the
show that we cut was if Oprah and
Beyonce this is morbid but we're on the
same flight of shocking
I think Oprah I think Oprah - but what
if it was the day after formation came
out we'd somebody the writers room said
that they would put out two different
editions of the paper that day he shot
this episode for four days and we had a
bunch of kids on the plane but not all
the kids could come for all four days
they were only allowed to I guess
legally work for two days or something
so they hired only twins everybody on
the plane is an identical twin
so in acts 1 and 2 it's one twin and
then in act 3 where you start screaming
it's their twin we got to there we were
like hi like we knew them and then
they're like hi one twin is gonna be
like I don't know it's like a fun party
and there one's gonna be like are you
sure this woman was just screaming about
her husband's dick I'll do the same show
you know what I think might help okay
as soon as I held Helen screamed just
tell I had bad energy Mae was kind of
like Helen was like putty in his hands
and then the hand off would happen the
pig was very happy very well and the
pigs owner was really nice I got ya I'm
very friendly with her
we text one another we had one
experience on SNL where we needed a
squirrel and this handler was like yes I
have a trained squirrel I will bring it
to you this girl does what I say and
also they were like we have to shoot at
night because the squirrel is driving
down from the Capitol girl was plummet
put on its mark camera the cameras
started rolling the squirrel immediately
just ran up into the rafters and then
the squirrels trainer was like it's we
just have to like wait for it to come I
don't know what should you know you
could train it but you also just like
[Laughter]
I'm starting tomorrow my name is Roberta
euro felicia carries dante chases miguel
we moved to south america we start over
what I think my favorite scenes to shoot
where the scenes that we went into the
bathroom was like watch Molly slowly
disintegrate yeah but we would do them
out of order and stuff and you're so
amazing in it and yeah all of us falling
apart at different times but like
watching you sort of like have that
veneer come off is really awesome that
was a big chunk to memorize and we were
shooting you know in New York and I
stated I think it was a Hilton to
memorize my monologue I went swimming
and there was like a glass-like window
so there was a prom going I'll always
memorize room so I was swimming
memorizing my lines waving to people
like at a prom Molly Shannon is swimming
and screaming and I swam for so long
because there was so much to memorize
that when I got out I had a charley
horse and I was like
that's gonna be their prom story they're
gonna be like ed my mom I went to dance
and I saw Molly Shannon just like
falling apart let's all have a laugh
let's all laugh at my dead husband mom
no one's laughing it's okay he was the
only man I ever loved I did not want him
to be a joke
in the first episode it says I miss dad
and they're like yeah I know I did too
but we didn't decide what that meant and
so I was like fun to figure out in the
room what happened to him yes he also
went back through kind of when we were
towards the end and out of the year of
yes through line for Pat's character
that was kind of like a later in the
game because we really liked this idea
that she we've seen her existing through
this whole season kind of like
repressing and making this new narrative
for herself as like a gung-ho woman
going for it and then when in this
episode where she finally lets that go
to the side it's very exciting to see
that woman give it up yeah I love the
part where she's like where she just
says explains why she didn't want to
tell chase and she's just like I just
didn't I just wanted to have a chance
it's like so hard right yeah
and then I just love how dignified she
is with the way she sees him how hard he
did try and yeah and just so so so
respectful and I guess being an Irish
Catholic with a long history of
alcoholics in my family I just felt like
it was just beautiful yeah she did want
him to be a joke I didn't want like me
to decide who he was yeah it's also not
just it's not so cut and dry any of this
anything is never just yeah he was a he
was a loser he was a bad guy it's never
that cut and dry so it's nice to tell
multiple sides of that story exactly
yeah multiple sides of it I've never
I've never performed anything like that
in my life I loved it I loved it it was
like
[Music]
you